[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to hop the Ricker do we talk about
what I'm clapping because we have
special people in the room he's very
special
[Music]
[Applause]
that's worse that's a consolation prize
right there
I'm here because it's not enough people
that's why we like you dude contribute
yeah they like it why'd you pause after
ha what do you pause that for I paused
yeah you like thought about it but what
about what when did i pause like at
what's part of the sentence after he
said contribute yeah really just like
that it was like really you thought
they're really in your head after you
said it though I said really and then I
said really like that maybe I had to say
it in my head and rehearse it before it
came out of my mouth
have you ever had a guest that was
horrible
multiple and that's never made to there
no man we let the Dadi and see how
[ __ ] up they are well you know it was
you're gonna have to watch all the video
I mean we touched it talked [ __ ] about
them - I have nuts
there's got a lot of guests and if you
don't see them come back it's usually
because they got too famous well we
don't like them not the only reasons
they're probably all the too famous is
because they're busy or that's truth oh
my god dude famous well it's not that
they don't like us it's it's hard well
for one
we're like in butt [ __ ] nowhere for a
lot of entertainers very weird we're
[ __ ] far right and like LA we're
really it takes people like an hour to
get here and they don't want to do that
and most people if you're on a podcast
or any type of show like you're in there
like an hour max and you get the [ __ ]
out right before us dude some of the
sessions last four to six hours you know
I was this close seeing around the park
this week and then I'm gonna be shooting
for oh my always fast like 1006 oh if
it's like an hour I could probably
squeeze it in
yeah I know maybe I'm a doll in two
weeks any thanks Randall it's cuz you're
not here I am I can offer to hold a
session for hey we were talking we were
buddies
and I thought that's that's that's
diving into deep we can't [ __ ] on the
first day like yeah you've been [ __ ]
doing cybersex already yeah but that's
not even the first date though true I
don't even met the dude have you met the
dude no but in time you don't meet
anyone yeah but that's a long commitment
man 10:06 you guys have never met
Randall yet no I never not in person
I think I almost came out in the skin
with him when Randall was doing a skit
with Wong foo and he was playing Santa
Claus the little kid in that skit was
supposed to be Isaac we had school
Randall's been in the kynges performance
before that's dull yeah he was a host of
a unforgettable gala you know that Corey
Andy before before it was like coriacea
it was like for mainly the Korean like I
remember yeah and he was a host one time
and we were performing and they wanted
us to make sure that the host was
somehow revealed that like so we like
had to meet up at Tech and were like hey
Randall oh you you're gonna close our
show so then we like gave him some of
our costumes and stuff in your show and
he was like why I'm cool about it and
he's really then he did fresh off the
boat so we were like oh yeah I super
down-to-earth a super show my favorite
um Randall Park thing that I've seen is
from the office his same gym yeah that
was funny
your god Jim and Dwight was actually
believing a I'm over it now like I'm
gonna be over the office like didn't
hurt something maybe that's why that's
true but um I was making a sound no
obviously I love the office but it's
just like I've watched it now maybe like
10 times through and I can't for the
life of me start anything else on
Netflix so I'll just keep putting it on
and then I'm like because I'm starting
to like hate Jim I
I hate their relationship they're the
worst relationship on the office I know
why why well why do you think it's the
worst because she dreams she was like
super selfish he wants to go first -
suddenly a company that he started and
she couldn't move there she could have
found another job but she was I wanna
stay here I don't want what she but she
did it in the end though but hold on
spoiler hold on a second
he started this company without telling
her [ __ ] so she had that palace
because she wouldn't like it okay but no
but he then eventually came out it's
like I don't know was fine by me like
eventually like she moved for him that's
all - no yeah they tried it for a little
bit I know she did and that's a no she
did she did you watch the finale bro he
moved back she was literally gonna cheat
on him with the sound guy what are you
on 9 he's just [ __ ] trolling down the
Bollywood version just break out at the
dance
yes yeah did you move that's the call
center bro that's not my office
are you legit like a ski matter are you
just being a troll no cuz I remember she
was literally like gonna cheat on him
yeah I know but then close to Jim Dell
moved right that's what Dell came back
and he was like oh like when he kind of
slipped out doctor's office ten times
and you don't remember the belly
no I remember that I'll see you in the
office so I'll have your funds all
crying but then what's it called hold on
robbery so this is to my knowledge then
chop the records defeated theme thinks
he knows the author this is more
important
watch I'm gonna watch it tonight you
guys are you wrong he's gonna watch ten
see you're saying that she moved for him
in the finale in the finale she sold the
house without him knowing and surprising
by saying we're [ __ ] moving to Austin
though yes oh that's a Philadelphia oh
that's the office that in that he had
his office in in Philadelphia oh really
yeah
well is a great segue no see they have
their office in Philadelphia and then I
think they moved to all trying to get
away Julia don't let him get away but
still still there's so much - that's a
real relationship where there's
compromise and that's why people like it
so much because it really I knew that
Siegel young man that Holly that Holly
and Holly Baxter that relationship
that's a that one felt like you I
thought he or she was cool yeah I feel
like [ __ ] Angela Dwight I love that -
they're forbidden love is so [ __ ]
funny literally make it forbidden
themselves so funny dude in like hell
Angelo got married to a politician I'm
like oh my god in an Oscar oh my I love
that show so much I love it but I just
hated it once Michael left how Andy like
they wrote him as this like he's like
the replacement Michael or I'm like no
just be Andy what the [ __ ] are you doing
there were so many lines or I'm like
this is such a Michael line I hate it
but like I I don't know how true this is
I actually didn't read up on this but
like I heard that they made they wrote
Andy a very despicable role at one point
in time because like I think he ditched
the office to do like the hangover or
something or like I think he made a
commitment to the office and then he was
like oh but the hangover contact I'm
gonna go to the hangover
and then I think I don't know I don't
know it could be pure speculation and
rumors but that's kind of what I heard
which is why he was like on a boat for
like I don't know like the whole season
could be they do that sometimes we're
like if someone has a personal issue or
work conflict you have to kill the
character off or right um awesome huh
yeah yeah which makes me wonder like if
it wasn't for those like situations how
would this show actually pan out
Oh like if it was a perfection those
exact situations make a show that yeah
because people know the backstory all
that happened ten years of shooting you
know you can't you get bored we wouldn't
fight like you're mad you're watching
Game of Thrones with just Jon Snow's
like I'm just gonna take a break first
there's not one season where a Daenerys
Targaryen I think she was going through
I felt which mental illness she had but
oh she had a suddenly I'm sorry and then
she yeah they had to minimize that her
didn't during an entire season yeah damn
or even back to the office I think that
season for when Angela was actually
pregnant so every single shot and the
whole season never shows her it's like
it's always like looking over the
cubicle walls and Ryan said all season
yeah they really shaved Meredith said no
you could tell us about cap but Jim they
just like a week ago
put out that no that's actually way old
it just I just be a resurface but I in
season three he had a wig the whole time
Oh times I feel like a little too
stressed out and I need to take a break
and this video is brought to you today's
pop the record is brought to you by
field take a disco when I discovered
feels it helped me out because it
basically I get stressed out sometimes I
need to take a break and you just chill
and if you guys are wondering what is
the fields fields is a premium CBD
delivered directly to your doorstep
what this feels do feels naturally helps
reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness
if you guys ever had CBD before Desha is
so relaxing mating like relaxes your
body right yeah kind of
like it ends up affecting like your
emotions too because your body your
emotions are connected yeah yeah it just
chills me out it's a real chill pill so
easy to take you place a few drops of
feels under your tongue it's like an oil
it's like a it's like a kind of like
that and the feel and feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about CVD is that finding your
right dose is important and everyone's
dose is different so leave room to
experiment over the course of a week or
so you may need to take more or less to
get the effects you're after there's
real human support are you new to CBD
well feels off offers a free CBD hotline
to help guide your personal experiment
experience you can feel better naturally
Fields works naturally to help you feel
better there's no high hangover or
addiction and I can attest to this
because I use it so membership join the
fields community to get feels delivered
to your door every month you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today by using by going to feels calm /
off the record and you'll get 50% off
your first order with free shipping
that's f a-l-s dot-com / off director to
become a member and get 50%
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping feels calm / off the
record they gave us some and then yeah
guy that you sent me a DM wanting to
know what the CBD product that we talked
about there you go whoa
CBD helps me sleep yeah yeah I like it
I've been doing it in my teeth I've been
putting a few drippity drops here and
there and then I sip it and I get that
relax I've had a CBD drink when we were
in in Portland oh and I was like whoa
does it taste weird I don't remember but
like I remember feeling weird about
about my body because I wasn't
accustomed to that my entire body was
relaxed yeah it's very like it was
relaxed but like but like my mind was
cleared I know what I feel
like and it was like my brain was normal
but my entire body was like jello yeah
it's pretty cool I for me though I think
that I just and build tolerance
extremely fast
so then mitosis has to get higher and
higher but for me I just like I'm just
kind of chill and then I do it like once
a week or just here and there whenever I
feel like I need to relax fast yeah I
just can't do like weed anymore
well it makes my body feel weird like
like smoke it smoking at edibles
anything if I was like let me try like
CBD but haven't I stopped how does it
make your body feel so it's like relax
you right like make your muscles
everything oh not always
yeah there's something so our pens on
the weed yeah some of it makes you hate
me I've tried I've tried I really did
conspiracies to everything gives me
conspiracies with that like with smoking
accused me awake but then like say like
my traps are tight right and I smoke or
do anything whatever the strain is I
suppose relax your back to your mind
like tie it up there happen to me with
morphine yeah I'd do up yes well yes
relax the cousin of the heroin thing oh
yeah after I got my appendix get out uh
you got appendix I don't so I can't put
you there no it's empty it's like a hole
is that is that like your first go to
when you when you like in self-defense
you just punch someone in the appendix
and hope that at first yep dangers do
this kill people right but like what
like if you have a tight muscle isn't it
best to have like more of a topical
application of CBD instead of like
actually well see video I haven't tried
it so a bump time but just like you know
what they see like smoke and you could
sleep for lives your body feels it kinda
like numb like the day way like this
after you hit the joint
yeah that's every time it's like like I
don't know what holders get off might be
might be mental it might not actually be
your shoulders being stiff you being
like really aware of what you were
smoking for in the first place
oh no I it no matter what even if I'm
out I don't I'm not thinking about it
I'm not trying to relax or anything I
just feel like these parts tight enough
I feel like my back like if I'm seen
like this I'll have to select this so
I'm not seeing like all [ __ ] up
and every single time the only place
that it ever feels good is Hawaii is
mental then that's all mental
that's regional for sure actually
Hawaiian la something about my traps man
I'll I just make this single mix way
can't don't go to New York then my
stress City I like high stress though as
I know it's at it's very metal they just
it just [ __ ] doesn't feel good sorry
that's why what to drinking and my
alcoholism self I personally never tried
CBD but me and the cousins we actually
bought CBD oil for my grandma music yeah
because like she's down with the weed
well I don't doesn't even know what it
is no my god you're drugging your ground
without it I mean she's in her a like
late 80s and like she I guess she at
that time we didn't quite know what was
what was wrong with her but we just knew
that she kind of had like a loss of
appetite and then like she was taking
medication by I guess just taking the
wrong kind of medication so like end of
that she had like gout or whatever but
at that time like how I it's like an
inflammation that happens in your joints
fluid and that crystallizes almost
caused it to be painful when everything
so yeah yeah yeah and so like she she
just wasn't um she just wasn't eating a
lot but she needed to eat something in
order for her to take her medication and
so we were like maybe we could just do
CBD oil and like help her out and maybe
help her with her appetite so like we
got one that's what specifically kind of
for that but I didn't I don't know I
didn't stay long enough to like quite no
but because I had to go but like yeah we
got it for her and she was like willing
and then like we're like hold it there
under your tongue for like 30 seconds
this she was just like like that and
birds are [ __ ] useless huh not
useless my grandma's like that to have
to tell her to do everything she just
sitting there they don't have to do [ __ ]
they've lived their life now it's time
for them to tell I just feel like this I
know that it's like hella old people
that are down to do like drugs and stuff
when they're way older when they're not
when they're young yeah my grandma was
still alive I [ __ ] smuggle some weed
to Japan and [ __ ] blaze what there
dude yeah so many like older communities
that are down to just try things for the
first time smoke weed all the time you
know do like a sit-in Soviet huh would
you what I'm like harder drugs do when
you're older
probably yeah the only thing I'd be
concerned with is like getting a heart
attack
oh I'll be like if I my face I'm like I
don't really care about like going I
would I definitely would want try heroin
all those hard like before I have to
know how a few Oh might seem like hard
drugs I don't know I don't know uh
wonderful hey you got a week left I
think he feels like DMT and stuff like
that you know I got good DMT if people
are down it wasn't safe I'll go right
now you have it yeah I want to do it Sam
if you have it I'll be down well I heard
shrooms is a similar experience it's
like a thousand times less they just eat
a thousand times more shrooms I'm eating
a thousand times the shoes is gonna do
it I mean I don't know I don't know uh I
don't know about you guys but during
this whole quarantine thing I think I I
got better at controlling my states
living by state look like California
Denver Hawaii State appealing emotional
state yeah I could shift it it's just
energy sad happy sad guy like I could
raise it up no it's too much already
angry and then jump straight to horny
nah
no no no it's powerful but like I mean
this is powerful it's [ __ ] crazy for
well cuz I live alone right so I can go
now
a whole week without actually any
physical contact with anyone and I can
control my contact with humans if I want
even touch each other
so you really don't have any human touch
at all yeah I literally didn't touch
anyone for almost a month and the only
person that I touched for a second was
Casey yeah did he make you horny nah
but it was interesting though because
yeah I think it's just it's just crazy
when you don't have humans around and
then it's almost like an addiction
because it's a distraction you
constantly have emotions you can share
with or whatever but then when you have
to work inward then you start to
discover all kinds of weird [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] it's crazy about yourself I'm
sure you had a lot of discoveries I want
to know what these discoveries are it's
hard to say cuz it's not a it's not a
thinking or it's a feeling it's like a
different perspective kind of thing like
a shift and you're not talking to anyone
so it's more like you're not you're not
communicating with yourself through
words it's more of like your your your
feelings inside yourself out loud when
you're at law no I will ice you know I
mean I just talk out loud or sing but
then I talk in my head yeah I discuss in
my head try to sort out a problem or
whatever I feel like a lot of people
most people do but then the weird ones
are the only not that weird but some
people don't have the inner thought they
have they have a blank mind the only is
see through pictures oh yeah why not
they're just dumb not like people think
it's either using actual words where
they're like speaking sentences remember
we talked about this I'm taking you and
then other people just see like images
they're like feelings I see both like
they don't think they think in feelings
and images versus actual sentences and
words yeah like like how people do both
right so like if you think about two
shoebox you're gonna see a picture of a
tissue box but then if
like Oh what am I gonna do say and
you're figuring it out it's not just
like random things you're actually
talking yourself right where other
people did just think like work out like
bench this that but it's not like an
actual dialogue going in their head do
you know it's a trip so my whole life I
had always done the nonverbal kind of
thinking and then once I started
realizing that all these nonverbal
thoughts were always negative like
negative emotions and like self-loathing
kind of emotions when and then once I
realized that I started actually putting
in dialogue in my brain of like actual
sentences and like making a conscious
effort to be positive with those
thoughts and then my whole like
everything internally like shifted
you're starting to control it I used to
I used to just speak like just speak
very authentically but now I got in
trouble for it because I'll just say
things without thinking right you know
you'll say [ __ ] without thinking so I
had to practice using English in my head
not just speaking from my heart I'd like
used English in my head to be like that
was the thing I wanted to say and then
try and say it so I had to practice that
in like high school and on and then now
I feel like it's a fluctuation like
having tact and what's the most
effective way for the situation totally
I'm like the opposite we're not saying
anything bad but then all have I'm so in
my own head I'll have these
conversations that like um and I get
caught out it a lot right even like see
like will be talked about taking news
and or anything we're just be talking
with friends I'll start saying things
are so out of what we're talking about
because I've already had that
conversation in my head so I'm like oh
we've had that conversation so my start
time others Ojo all the time we have to
catch up with his brain yeah yeah so
it's like people people are on the same
wavelength I mean but I'm just like I'm
gonna I just have people here I'm gonna
go into crazy tangent just who gives a
[ __ ]
you never come off as like hard to catch
though not hard to catch but like we're
at the barbecue of Father's Day and
we're in the in the jacuzzi a shower
tunnel and everyone was like why the
[ __ ] did you bring that up now and I'm
like oh I've been talking about that in
my head for like ten minutes already so
you guys are late on this conversation
how dare you be late yeah oh I do that
for days
[Music]